I'm looking at the grow-need products. Is there a benefit to getting the grow-need sheet over the
grow-need mat? Good question. Why would you use the grow-need sheet or the grow-need mat? What's
the better one to buy? So the grow-need sheet is a different material. So here's the grow-need sheet.
So the grow-need sheet is a very lightweight material that's got the fibers in it that will then
go back through this wire, then you attach this wire that section right there to the sheet. It's
got a snap to it, but then this goes to the wall ground, out to the ground in the ground.
This is a very lightweight material that's easy to sleep on, and you know, you're stuck in a
irritate your body and cause you any ill health as far as sleep goes. And you get you put this,
like we talked about last week, just on the lower half of your bed across your whole bed.
It's a pretty big piece of material. So we have people that get this and use this, not just
will you have them leave it on their bed because you put it underneath your fitted sheet so you don't
have to take it off. So it stays on there permanently, but people use this and just sit on this as a
grow-need pad too. So the difference between the two is the grow-need pad is made up of a different
material. So here's the material for the grow-need pad. So it's more of like a foamy type material.
So it looks better on a chair. So typically you use a grow-need pad for a daytime use on a chair
and use the grow-need sheet on your bed. You could use the grow-need pad on your bed too, but
that's typically not the purpose of it. But to be honest, I have had people get this and use this
on their chair too and just cover their chair with it or they can fold it up and sit on it and
so you can use it anyway. They both plug into the wall with a thing like this the same way. They both
have the same basically operation. The grow-need sheet is going to cover a greater amount of your body
if you're rolling around in bed and such. So it's just a different application, but they do the exact
same thing.